[Music]
three seconds go by three you wanted new
drug
you could have just asked me the device
that controls every military satellite
in the world
just fallen into the hands of four very
dangerous guy we need someone who can
move like them fight like them it's time
to be patriot there are no more Patriots
just rebel and tyrants so which are you
I'm xxx
I'll introduce you to your ground team
all right it comes Red Bulls poster
child I'm not gonna have clowns watch my
back who would you trust a good the
extreme completely insane what you want
I got what you need now that's the team
I can work with
freshing you have to know what you're
doing down there yeah that's what she
says Wow these guys have y'all said the
real kind of trouble you have no idea
what you're up against
whatever it is they're looking for gonna
come up short this is me you're not
making me breakfast in the body we're
willing to die you keep the world safe
how about you I live for this I guess
we're on the same team now you ready to
have some fun I go look I'll go
we simplify sleep kick some ass
get the girl and try to look dope why
are you doing
Danah feels good to be back you know
they say the world is safer than has
ever been in the history of civilization
do you feel safer today than you did
yesterday I know I don't
the world has changed the war we're
fighting today
needs a different kind of soldier
we need people with the skills and the
attitude
to take on threats we don't even know
exist
we need someone who can walk into a
tornado and come out the other side like
a lizard dam gentle breeze one in the
back you could have just asked me
let me simplify for you kick some ass
and try to look dope why are you doing
I could definitely make that work
guns girls global domination
and the cages back
damn I can work with here we go
it's refreshing you actually know what
you're doing